Namo Tassa Bhagavato Parahato Sama Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Parahato Sama Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Parahato
Hommage au Bouddha, le noble, bienheureux, pleinement éveillé de par lui-même.
Je ne me souviens pas de ce dont j'ai parlé l'an dernier, donc j'espère que cela ne va pas être une répétition.
et je pense que je vais donc discuter de la question de la libre volonté.
Juste une petite chose, est-ce que je peux avoir une personne ressource, mais une seule, pour l'anglais ?
J'ai parfois des questions de vocabulaire.
Ok, ça marche.
Super.
Alors,
D'une manière générale, il y a trois positions parmi les philosophes.
D'un côté, il y a les fatalistes.
Il n'y a aucune liberté dans la volonté.
C'est une illusion de le penser et tout est conditionné d'après eux.
Et même dans le temps des Bouddhas, il y avait un enseignant qui disait que si on allait sur l'un côté des Ganges avec l'amour et la compassion, et qu'on allait sur l'autre côté avec le meurtre et la menace, ça ne ferait pas de différence pour votre calme.
Et même au temps du Bouddha, une personne a dit, si vous allez d'un côté du Gange plein d'amour et de compassion, et de l'autre plein de meurtres et de mauvaises actions, cela ne fera aucune différence.
C'est une question de karma.
Tout était conditionné.
Et à l'extrémité opposée, il y avait des gens qui croyaient en la liberté totale de la volonté, le libre arbitre.
On les appelait les libertariens.
Jean-Paul Sartre était un libertarien, dans mon opinion.
Il a dit que c'était une position philosophique.
A chaque moment de conscience, vous avez le choix.
Et donc, chaque moment vous offre
Et donc chaque moment vous offre la possibilité de faire une action selon votre libre arbitre.
Mais il a dit aussi également que ce n'était pas faisable.
Donc il y a ces deux extrêmes et la plupart des gens sont entre les deux.
Et on les appelle les compatibilistes.
Un peu de conditionnement et un peu de libre arbitre en même temps.
Alors, comment le Bouddha pensait que les choses survenaient ?
Donc il faut que nous revenions à ce qu'il appelait les lois basiques de la causalité.
Souvenez-vous que le Bouddha ne se préoccupe que de la conscience humaine.
Il ne s'intéresse qu'au monde que nous créons et expérimentons.
Il ne se préoccupe pas de ce que nous appellerions le monde objectif scientifique.
Alors cette loi s'appelle la loi de ceci et cela.
Donc quand ça est survenu dans le passé, alors ceci survient dans le présent.
Quand cela n'est pas survenu dans le passé, alors ceci ne survient pas.
C'est ce que nous comprenons en général sous le terme de causalité.
Par exemple, chacun d'entre vous dans le passé a dû prendre la décision de venir à ce cours.
Et vous voilà.
Et si vous n'aviez pas pris cette décision, si vous aviez décidé de ne pas venir, alors vous ne seriez pas là.
C'est plutôt simple.
Mais si l'univers était basé sur cela,
Mais si l'univers était fondé sur ça, d'où alors vient la créativité ?
Cela conduirait à penser un univers qui est très répétitif, n'est-ce pas ?
Alors l'autre possibilité également, c'est parce que ça, enfin parce que ceci c'est ici, alors ceci survient également, en même temps.
Et si ceci n'est pas ici, alors ceci, ou il y a deux fois ceci, mais enfin cet autre ceci, il n'est pas là non plus.
Ils sont liés mais ils surviennent en même temps ou pas.
Alors,
Alors chacun d'entre vous a décidé, venant d'endroits différents du monde, de venir à cette retraite.
Et quand vous êtes arrivés, et les autres aussi sont arrivés, vous personnellement, alors la retraite a pu commencer.
Si pour une raison ou une autre vous étiez mort en chemin, alors cette retraite n'aurait pas pu avoir lieu.
Et je serais très triste.
Et donc si l'univers était gouverné par une relation d'immédiateté entre les différents phénomènes, on pourrait présumer qu'il y aurait une créativité énorme.
Mais aucun ordre.
Ce serait le chaos, n'est-ce pas ?
Et quand on met ces deux phénomènes ensemble, on a une idée de comment les choses surviennent.
Ça, ça s'appelle la loi du ceci et du cela.
Iddha Pachayata.
Il faut le dire avec l'accent français, ça veut traduire.
Sinon on ne peut pas le comprendre.
Quand on a l'idée que le monde ne peut pas être prévu,
Donc il ne peut être ni prévu ni prévisible parce qu'il n'est pas complètement conditionné par le passé.
Pas uniquement par le passé, il est aussi conditionné par ce qui se passe dans le présent.
Donc le monde est conditionné à la fois par ce qui se passe dans le passé et à la fois par ce qui se passe dans le présent.
Donc même si l'un d'entre vous n'était pas conditionné
Et si uniquement l'un d'entre vous n'était pas venu, alors ça aurait été juste une retraite un tout petit peu différente.
Maintenant, au-dessus de cela, il y a ce qui est connu comme les 5 lois.
Et au-dessus de tout cela, il y a ce qui est connu comme les cinq lois.
Et ça, ça va très bien avec la manière dont nous, nous voyons le monde.
Et donc le premier, c'est la loi de la chaleur.
Et ça, ça revient à notre physique et à notre chimie.
C'est la loi de la chaleur, du feu, de l'énergie.
Donc maintenant,
Donc maintenant, quand on revient à notre karma personnel, on ne peut pas dire que quelque chose qui survient de la nature est notre karma personnel.
Si vous marchez le long de la route et il y a un tremblement de terre, la terre s'ouvre et vous tombez dedans.
Et on ne peut pas dire que c'est parce que vous avez, dans votre vie antérieure, tué tellement de poulets.
Down the well.
On peut dire que, de manière évidente, cela fait partie d'un karma plus général qui consistait à être né ou à passer à cet endroit à ce moment-là.
Mais à mon avis, ce serait impossible de le connecter avec quelque chose que vous avez fait.
ou que vous n'avez pas fait.
Le second est bijoukama, qui signifie la loi des semences.
Alors, le second, c'est la loi des semences.
La génétique.
Donc, encore une fois, si quelqu'un est né avec une maladie génétique,
Ici, de nouveau, si quelqu'un est né avec une maladie génétique, on ne peut pas dire que c'est parce qu'il a fait quelque chose de terrible dans une vie antérieure.
Ou a échoué à faire ce qu'il aurait dû faire dans une vie antérieure.
On sait que cela fait partie de notre histoire génétique.
Donc ça, il faut le séparer du karma personnel.
Il y a des gens qui disent qu'il y a une connexion entre les deux.
Vous connaissez le Père Pio, en Italie ?
Vous connaissez le Père Pile en Italie ?
Le Padré Pio.
Un homme est venu le voir et lui a dit « Pourquoi suis-je devenu aveugle ?
» Alors qu'il était en train de se confesser.
Et il lui a dit « C'est parce que vous avez battu votre père.
»
Peut-être qu'il avait eu un peu d'insight dans la vie personnelle de cette personne, de vision.
Ce que nous faisons a des conséquences physiques.
Mais si vous pouvez connecter une maladie génétique avec quelque chose que quelqu'un a fait dans le passé, ça serait difficile, je pense.
Mais qu'on puisse le connecter avec une maladie génétique ou avec quelque chose que nous avons fait dans le passé, cela est difficile.
La troisième, c'est la loi de l'esprit.
C'est ce que nous appelons la psychologie.
Et à travers toutes les psychologies individuelles, on peut en déduire une sociologie, comment les gens vivent ensemble.
Donc il y a certaines choses qui nous sont données.
Nos sens.
Si vous êtes colorblind,
Si vous ne voyez pas la couleur, alors vous ne verrez pas la couleur de la même manière que les gens ordinaires la voient.
L'altonien, oui.
Si vous êtes né mort, alors bien sûr, le niveau de communication est réduit.
Donc si vous êtes né sourd, alors il y a un niveau de communication qui est diminué par rapport aux gens qui ne le sont pas.
Et même si vous avez uniquement des problèmes de surdité, que vous entendez mal, alors ce niveau de communication est plus bas.
Et également votre capacité à mémoriser les choses, à les comprendre.
Ça c'est aussi quelque chose qui nous est donné.
On aimerait tous être des génies.
Je n'ai jamais surmonté ma déception.
L'ensemble du processus de perception est donné.
Juste la manière dont les yeux voient quelque chose et puis créent une photocopie dans l'esprit, une perception.
Et puis comment avec une perception similaire on forme des concepts.
Tout ça c'est donné.
Ça c'est l'esprit.
Cela inclut également le cœur, les sentiments, les ressentis.
Même d'un point de vue génétique, la physicalité de notre nature est donnée.
Et même la manière dont votre langue goûte la nourriture, elle le fait à sa manière particulière, elle ne va pas le faire de la même manière que quelqu'un d'autre.
Et quand vous sentez quelque chose, par exemple le parfum d'une fleur, cela vous est spécifique ?
C'est une réaction chimique qui vous est propre ?
Peut-être que les gens seront d'accord, mais ce ne sera pas la même chose.
Si vous voulez que les autres sentent la rose de la manière dont vous la sentez, alors il faut leur prêter votre nez.
Donc vous pouvez voir que le monde que nous expérimentons est très individuel.
Alors vous voyez, le monde dont nous faisons l'expérience est très individuel.
Et le quatrième, c'est le karma, la loi morale.
On y reviendra.
Et le dernier, le cinquième, c'est la loi spirituelle.
Je parlerai peut-être de cela de manière plus détaillée demain.
Mais en ce qui concerne le bouddhisme, bien sûr, il s'agit des enseignements du Bouddha.
Les quatre nobles vérités,
le noble que tu peux sentir, l'interdépendance originelle.
Donc si on revient au karma, le karma c'est la loi morale entre les êtres humains.
Je pense que le bouddhisme dirait entre tous les êtres humains.
Et même le bouddhisme dirait entre tous les êtres vivants.
Et les animaux les plus évolués à coup sûr ont des attributs moraux.
Lorsqu'une tigresse défend ses petits contre un mâle qui les attaque, elle le fera quitte à en mourir.
Mais en général, elle arrive à chasser le mal.
Mais pas sans blessures.
Donc on peut être très scientifique à ce sujet.
Parler d'hormones.
Mais dans des termes bouddhistes, il y a un esprit.
Et l'esprit n'est pas le corps.
Il y aura bien sûr des écrivains du buddhisme qui diront que le cerveau est la tête.
Il y a bien sûr des écrivains bouddhistes qui vont dire que le cerveau est l'esprit.
Vous êtes peut-être tombé sur le livre qui s'appelle « L'esprit du Bouddha ».
Et au début de ce livre ils disent très clairement oui il y a quelque chose de transcendant.
Mais le cerveau et l'esprit.
Ce n'est pas vrai d'après les enseignements du Bouddha.
Je ne sais pas comment ils sont parvenus à cette conclusion.
Mais des bouddhistes très séculiers croient cela.
Pour ceux que cela intéresse, il y a un très bon essai, je suis en train de penser à son nom, d'un philosophe, appelé « Qu'est-ce que ça a l'air d'être un bat ?
»
Il y a un très bon essai écrit par un philosophe qui dit qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être une chauve-souris ?
La connexion entre les chimiques et les impulses électriques et le monde phénoménal que nous expérimentons ne peut pas être montrée.
La connexion entre la chimie intérieure, les impulsions électriques et le monde extérieur, on ne peut pas la démontrer.
Et la manière dont vous faites l'expérience du monde phénoménal.
Donc ça, ça ne peut pas être démontré, scientifiquement.
Et ce philosophe dit, c'est impossible de montrer ça.
Mais c'est autre chose.
Karma est ce...
Le Kama, c'est cette loi morale fondamentale qui dit, si vous faites quelque chose avec un bon cœur, alors il en ressortira quelque chose de bon.
Avec une bonne intention.
et si vous faites quelque chose avec une intention malhabile ou alors quelque chose ou une intention non bénéfique alors quelque chose de non bénéfique en surviendra donc quand on fait quelque chose cela a un effet sur le monde là
sur la matrix extérieure.
Mais cela a aussi un effet sur la psychologie intérieure, sur la matrix intérieure.
Et le Bouddha dit que chaque chose commence avec une pensée.
Chaque chose commence avec une pensée, puis une intention, et après on fait quelque chose.
Et alors cette intention, elle a aussi un effet sur l'esprit, sur notre monde intérieur, sur notre vie intérieure.
Donc à ce moment-là,
Pendant ce week-end, il y a eu toutes ces manifestations contre le changement climatique.
Et dans le monde entier.
Il y a des gens qui sont si engagés qu'ils sont prêts à être arrêtés.
Ce qu'ils espèrent, c'est qu'avec ces manifestations, de plus en plus de gens vont s'impliquer.
Le philosophe derrière le mouvement Extinction Rebellion, ou l'un d'entre eux en tous les cas, il dit que ça prend seulement 3,5% de la population pour créer une révolution.
Il a dit qu'il suffit de 3,5% d'une population pour créer une révolution.
Il a dit quelque chose du genre, s'il y a 3,5% de la population dans les rues, pour chaque personne dans la rue, il y en a 10 qui la soutiennent.
Alors maintenant, il y a quelqu'un qui se fait arrêter, qui prend une amende.
Donc, il a une bonne intention et finalement, il récolte de la souffrance.
Ça ne semble pas très juste.
Donc, il y a aussi, dans le loi du calme,
Donc, dans la loi du Kama, il est aussi compris que quelqu'un est prêt à faire des sacrifices pour les autres.
Mais où va être le bénéfice ?
Le bénéfice sera intérieur.
Le sentiment de...
Le sentiment de dignité.
Qu'on a été en réalité fidèles à nos engagements personnels.
Cette histoire de karma n'a rien à voir avec le bonheur.
au sens ordinaire de se sentir heureux.
Il y a un bonheur qui est beaucoup plus profond que le bonheur émotionnel.
Sinon, comment expliqueriez-vous les gens qui luttent pour la démocratie et finissent torturés ?
Et ils savent que cela fait partie des choses possibles.
Donc, il y a notre propre psychologie interne, notre propre vie spirituelle interne.
Donc il y a notre psychologie intérieure particulière, notre vie spirituelle intérieure particulière qui peut requérir de nous la souffrance.
C'est quelque chose qui n'est pas très bien compris d'une manière ordinaire en Orient.
On avait un vieux monsieur qui, de manière habituelle, s'occupait du monastère, le nettoyait, balayait.
Je crois qu'il était un comptable à la retraite.
Je ne suis pas sûr.
En tous les cas, c'était quelqu'un de très éduqué.
Et un jour, je lui ai dit, mais pourquoi pensez-vous, à votre avis, quelle est l'explication au sujet du fait que Jésus-Christ a été crucifié ?
Il a répondu, il a sans doute fait quelque chose d'épouvantable dans une de ses vies antérieures.
Il n'y a rien à dire à cela.
Donc le concept de souffrir pour le bénéfice des autres n'est pas répandu en Orient.
Et ça, ce serait du karma bon, positif.
Ils ont aussi une vue très fataliste du karma.
Et c'est particulièrement le cas dans l'hindouisme.
En Orient, ils ont la tendance de voir les choses d'une manière beaucoup plus fataliste que nous.
Quand le tsunami a déferlé sur le Sri Lanka, beaucoup de gens ont été tués, beaucoup de destruction.
Beaucoup de gens sont morts, il y a eu beaucoup de destructions.
J'ai entendu dire que des conseillers occidentaux sont allés là-bas pour aider.
Pour aider à faire face au trauma, au traumatisme.
Syndrome.
le syndrome post-traumatique.
Et quand ils sont allés là-bas, ils n'ont pas vraiment trouvé des gens qui souffraient du syndrome post-traumatique.
Parce qu'il y avait beaucoup plus d'acceptation du désastre.
Soit c'était vu comme un karma personnel, soit...
Oui, c'était l'impermanence, anicca.
Une partie des bénéfices de voir le monde d'un point de vue bouddhiste, c'est que cela nous évite des problèmes psychologiques terribles.
Et bien sûr, ce n'est pas parce que l'on fait quelque chose de merveilleux dans le monde que le monde le verra comme tel.
Il y avait une charité, je crois, dans une petite ville, Totnes, en Angleterre.
Il y avait donc une société de bienfaisance dans une petite ville en Angleterre.
Et ils envoyaient des vêtements en Afrique.
Et en fait, ce qui s'est passé, c'est que d'un point de vue local, il y avait donc
des gens qui faisaient les vêtements et en fait ils n'ont plus de travail.
Et alors toute l'économie locale s'est effondrée.
Donc en fait ils ont dû rapatrier leurs vêtements.
Ou alors en tous les cas au moins arrêter d'en envoyer.
Donc, en fait, on ne sait pas quel va être l'effet d'une action parce qu'on ne connaît pas les circonstances de l'être des autres.
C'est la même chose avec l'idée d'accident.
Donc, par exemple, vous pourriez être en train de marcher sur les escaliers, hein ?
Par exemple, vous descendez les escaliers.
Et vous loupez une marche.
Et vous tombez et vous renversez le café partout.
Et votre très proche ami bouddhiste dit...
Et votre ami bouddhiste très proche vous dit...
Tu devrais faire les choses avec plus de conscience, tu devrais être davantage en pleine conscience.
Et tu veux l'étrangler.
Les accidents, les accidents se font toujours parce que nous ne savons pas les conditions.
Les accidents surviennent parce qu'on ne connaît pas les conditions.
Peut-être ce qui s'est passé, c'est que quand ils ont regardé l'escalier, il y avait peut-être du liquide sur une marche qui les a fait glisser.
Donc en fait c'est quelque chose de difficile à faire, de connecter quelque chose qui nous arrive avec quelque chose du passé.
C'est mieux de le voir juste comme une loi générale.
D'une manière générale, quand vous faites quelque chose de bon, de bien, alors il en survient des choses bonnes, même si c'est tout petit.
Et l'inverse est vrai.
Pour vous montrer comment...
donc pour vous montrer comment la loi du karma peut devenir très absolue il y a une histoire qui vient du Dhammapada et cette histoire est racontée aux enfants
Il y avait un bateau sur l'océan.
Et bien qu'il y avait beaucoup de vent, le bateau, le navire s'est arrêté.
Et le capitaine n'a pas compris pourquoi.
Il avait un groupe de monstres à bord.
Il avait beaucoup de chance parce qu'il y avait un groupe de moines à bord.
Et donc il leur a demandé de trouver pourquoi.
Ils sont rentrés dans une méditation très profonde.
Et ils ont découvert que la cause de tout cela était sa femme.
Et ils ont découvert que la cause de tout cela, c'était sa femme.
Dans sa vie antérieure, elle avait noyé beaucoup de chats, etc.
La seule manière de remettre le navire en mouvement, c'était de jeter la femme par-dessus bord.
Et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait, le navire a recommencé à naviguer.
Si on vous raconte cela quand vous êtes enfant, comment est-ce que vous verrez le monde quand quelque chose arrive ?
Donc, pour moi, c'est quand même un peu plus subtil que ça.
Donc, on revient à cette question du libre-arbitre.
Donc,
Le Bouddha a dit, tout est conditionné.
Tout est conditionné par quelque chose d'autre, par tout le reste.
Donc, dans le conditionnement de notre esprit et de notre société, alors où réside le libre arbitre, le soi-disant libre arbitre ?
Vous pouvez lire d'autres auteurs qui ont peut-être une compréhension légèrement différente de la mienne.
Je pense que si au lieu de se focaliser sur le libre arbitre, on va davantage sur la question du discernement, alors on comprend mieux les choses.
Donc, souvenez-vous, nous commençons toujours d'une position d'illusion.
Et la définition même de l'illusion, c'est qu'on ne sait pas qu'on est dans l'illusion.
On n'y croit pas.
Donc, par exemple, si vous aviez à prendre une marche d'ici jusqu'à Boul,
Par exemple, si vous aviez à faire une balade, ou tout du moins à marcher d'ici jusqu'à Bulle, et vous ne connaissez pas le chemin, alors vous prenez une carte.
Et quand vous marchez, vous tombez sur une fourche.
Alors vous regardez votre carte.
Et grâce au discernement qui vous est permis grâce à la carte, vous prenez le bon chemin pour arriver où vous le souhaitez.
Et si vous n'avez pas de carte, alors peut-être que vous allez prendre le mauvais chemin.
Et vous arrivez devant une très grande montagne.
Et vous vous dites, ça c'est pas bulle.
Alors vous faites demi-tour.
Et après vous prenez le bon chemin sur la droite.
Donc, spirituellement, nous avons une certaine direction.
D'un point de vue spirituel, nous avons une certaine direction.
Si on suit le chemin bouddhiste, le Bouddha a dit qu'à la fin du chemin, il y a la libération de la souffrance.
Donc, nous allons ensemble et nous venons d'un forfait
Donc, on marche sur ce chemin, on arrive à une fourche où il faut prendre une décision.
Alors, on peut consulter les enseignements bouddhistes.
On peut les comprendre de travers.
On peut penser, je sais la façon.
On peut aussi se dire, moi, je connais le chemin.
Et on arrive devant la montagne.
Et on se dit, ah, mince, ce n'est pas ça.
On fait demi-tour et alors de cette manière, ça nous a aidé à discerner quel chemin on veut prendre et quel chemin il faut prendre pour aller là-bas.
Si une personne n'a aucune direction, aucun endroit où elle souhaite aller, elle ne sait pas où elle va.
N'importe quel chemin, il conduira.
Ils seront sans cesse en train d'aller et venir et de terminer devant une montagne.
Alors, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Est-ce qu'on a un libre arbitre ou est-ce qu'on a un tout petit peu de choix ?
Quand on a décidé d'une direction, what was the last piece ?
Do you have any free will if you've set your direction ?
Est-ce qu'on a un certain degré de lien parapite une fois qu'on a choisi une direction ?
So now, you have that extra biscuit on the plate.
Maintenant, vous avez ce deuxième biscuit sur la suite.
Et vous avez un problème.
Est-ce que vous allez prendre le chemin de la libération que vous connaissez très bien ?
Ou bien est-ce que vous allez aller à la montagne ?
Vous vous retrouvez devant la montagne.
Donc, d'une certaine manière, on a le choix.
Je peux seulement espérer que mes mots ont été d'une quelconque assistance.
Que je n'ai pas provoqué encore davantage de confusion.
Et que vous serez délivré de toutes vos souffrances plutôt que plus tard.